let's go to our caller from 8:05 caller
from 8:05 who's there hello that's you
yeah who's this oh hello my name is
Christopher go ahead Christopher oh yes
I had a question I liked else on this
thing yeah do you think the Second
Amendment is a little outdated
because there's the phrasing like a
well-regulated militia yeah and there's
all sort of part people argue about the
right to bear arms yeah I think we all
can agree that like which amendment is
it this is like the quartering soldiers
like no soldier certamen da like B
quarter in a house up for consent or
thirty minutes
I don't could agree that one's it I
think that's the third amendment yeah
yeah that we all could agree like down a
little outdated do you think the Second
Amendment is a little outdated of
quarters are the wording yeah of course
and listen it's not even just because of
the wording like the weld there's
different interpretations of what
well-regulated militia means allez allez
understanding would be that by regulated
we mean regulation in the sense of gun
safety regulations the constitutional
fetishists and second amendment fetishes
will say well-regulated means
well-equipped not actual regulation I
say we forget about that for a moment
it's been 250 years right the idea of
what it meant to have firearms at the
time is actually reflected really well
in this funny funny but sort of sad
commercial where someone comes in
disgruntled to a workplace and then they
say I'm gonna shoot up the place and
then they start putting gunpowder and
going through the process of rearming
their musket and of course by the time
they can fire off a shot the entire
floor in the office building has been
completely cleared out and it sort of
exposes that what it even meant to bear
arms at the individual level when the
Second Amendment was written bears no
connection to to what it is today and
you're absolutely right and it kind of
comes down to an argument of
constitutional originalism versus
constitutional realism sort of to
simplify and I could not agree with you
more yeah because man-friend were
talking and we went back and forth in it
and I was like telling him like the
founding fathers didn't really know
about ar-15s or 1847 listen anywhere
like muskets and like single-shot firing
get weapons completely yeah yeah
couldn't couldn't have said it better
myself thanks appreciate the call
drinky David all right very good